[Música]
estamos hechos de historias no hay un
solo ser vivo en el planeta que no
guarde en la memoria de su vida una
historia que contar una historia propia
que nos marca y nos define pero también
una historia en común una historia que
nos conecta en la inmensidad del tiempo
vivimos del cuento y libramos la emoción
cada vez que escuchamos esas tres
palabras mágicas que nos transportan a
reinos muy muy lejanos con seres
fantásticos había una vez
no recuerdo la primera vez que escuché
estas palabras pero sí recuerdo la
primera vez que la ley tendría unos
siete años estaba en una biblioteca
pública y encontré un libro de hans
christian andersen recuerdo la sensación
al comenzar a leerlo al ver a las
ilustraciones recuerdo el olor la
textura y hasta el peso de aquel libro y
fue entonces cuando me di cuenta que ese
era mi mundo que quería vivir ahí donde
mi mente volada y el cuento creció
conmigo más bien venía siempre a mi lado
era joven niña la que le contaba
historias a mi abuelita historias que
siempre tenían una trama y un desenlace
diferente me apasionada por leer nuevos
cuentos
aprenderme los y compartirlos con otras
personas
cuando llegaron mis hijos redescubrir lo
maravilloso que es la imaginación y cada
noche en su cuarto nacían nuevos cuentos
los más disparatados increíbles que nos
hacían lo mismo reír que soñar que nos
convertían en cómplices de aventuras que
nos unían nosotros veíamos hadas en las
libélulas y veíamos seres fantásticos
correr entre los árboles cuando
viajábamos en carretera mis hijos se
convirtieron en asiduos lectores en
imaginantes y eso en un país en donde
cada vez menos personas leen es un gran
logro e imagina antes somos todos y
comenzamos a usar la imaginación desde
muy temprana edad con las nanas las
regalías los juegos de manos que son
parte de la tradición oral y que están
ahí para despertar nuestra creatividad y
nuestra imaginación
las mamás por ejemplo que en todas
partes del mundo sin importar
el idioma tienen el mismo
que cuentan historias pequeñas el mismo
ritmo
tendenciosa
suave
que nos llena de tranquilidad que nos
recuerda el latido del corazón y hace
sentir a los bebés cómodos
y seguros
a la rodilla
arrollar duermas en mi niño duermas en
ella este pequeñito piernas yo de noche
quiero que lo lleven a pasear en coche
duermas en mi niño duerma se mega porque
había en el coco y te comerás
mediten también de los juegos de manos
esos que además nos ayudan a la
coordinación pom pom papá remedio para
tu papá pom pom pom el dedito en el
bordón papas y papas para mamá a las
camaritas para papá papas y papas para
mamá las camaritas para pasar
qué hacemos con magia aunque no siempre
somos conscientes de eso pero los
cuentos son precisamente eso magia los
cuentos nos encantan nos transforman no
se quejen nos curan
y los cuentos son creativos hace poco
tiempo descubrimos que mi hijo mayor es
asperger y resulta que aquellos cuentos
de su infancia fueron la terapia
perfecta para su desarrollo social y
afectivo convirtiéndolo en un ser humano
maravilloso con una capacidad
intelectual artística y humana enorme un
ser que puede ser que puede conectar con
la naturaleza y que disfruta de la
poesía aunque no entiende del todo las
metáforas y podría darles una lista
larguísima de los beneficios que les
trae a cada uno de ustedes escucha el
cuentos como cómo activar la memoria
como cómo hacer crecer el vocabulario
fomentar la lectura la empatía y nuestro
desarrollo social no saben una cosa
ustedes ya lo saben porque así como el
cuento ha crecido conmigo
el cuento siempre ha estado con cada uno
de ustedes
no me cree
cierren todos los ojos e imaginen un
espacio imaginando una biblioteca miren
las paredes los colores de ellas miren
los estantes llenos de libros y en este
espacio de pronto está caminando un ser
pequeñito un ser pequeño con una sonrisa
franca y hermosa como la tuya
porque ese ser pequeñito eres tú de niño
ahora acércate un instante como un libro
y que tú quieras
ábrelo comienza a ver las ilustraciones
siente siente su textura su peso su
dolor y ahora evoca el sentimiento que
sientes al leer esas tres palabras
mágicas que te transportan
había una vez
recuerda que el libro que cambió tu
infancia piense lo que hizo por ti
guarda ese recuerdo en el corazón y
compártelo con los demás
ahora abran los ojos pero abra los muy
bien para que se den cuenta que todos
absolutamente todos vivimos del cuento
[Aplausos]